well new research finds that work
provided technology has nearly half of
employees frustrated it's a situation
that has 26 percent of those fed up
workers considering new jobs here's more
the concept of the everyday workplace
has certainly changed employee
expectations gone are the days when
money and benefits helped with retention
here at avanti we wanted to understand
how technology shapes
employees daily work experience we found
70 percent of employees report the way
they interact with technology directly
impacts morale 65 saying they'll be more
productive if their technology was
updated employees are striving for
flexibility and productivity there are
two tips that i hear over and over again
from firms i've talked to hundreds and
hundreds of them the first is around
being organized and coordinated the
other big thing i hear about is around
security and connectivity that
highlights the importance of making
systems secure so don't get hacked and
also making sure you know you connect
with us as avanti that's our goal we've
created a platform called neurons it's
powered with hyper automation it will
actively solve issues and before anyone
is aware of them learn more at
ivanti.com experience
in las vegas now